hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the key features and indeed
contributions made by Martin Heidegger's
philosophy is the emphasis on mood or
attunement which includes the the
modalities of feeling emotion all of
these sorts of things that we understand
is effectivity is absolutely central in
human existence and is having a set of
metaphysical implications and and depth
that we want to explore and this comes
up very importantly in his address what
is metaphysics about halfway through the
piece it comes up in a way to deal with
a problem that has been posed and so
that's where we begin in thinking about
this through the intellect through logic
through the sciences we've tried to
explore the nothing and we looked at
this definition nothing is the complete
negation of the totality of beings and
was it possible for us as finite
creatures to actually encompass the
totality of beings Heidegger said you
can't actually think it you can imagine
it and then think that you've actually
negated the totality of beings but you
haven't really done so another way of
putting this is can we actually
comprehend can we take in the totality
of the whole of beings in themselves not
just in an imaginary way but in an
actual way and the answer is no as
finite beings we cannot do that and we
might also say as being stationed within
the very totality we're also not able to
do that as well
so it seems like we have arrived at a
dead end in this exploration of the
nothing and here is where Heidegger
turns to this thematic of mood that is
going to get us something like a
relation to the totality of beings in a
way that the intellect itself can
do so so how does he do this he says as
surely as we can never comprehend
absolutely the whole of beings in
themselves
we certainly do find ourselves stationed
in the midst of beings that are revealed
somehow as a whole so we do find
ourselves in the middle of being and
beings and he says in the end an
essential distinction prevails between
comprehending the whole of beings and
themselves and finding oneself in the
midst of beings as a whole so the
intellect the imagination attempt to
grapple with this one modality of
comprehending and fail at doing so but
another way is through experience of
finding ourselves in the midst of being
and Heidegger then goes on and says look
the former is impossible in principle we
can't do it but the latter happens all
the time in our existence in our
everyday existence he says he says it
seems as though we cling to this or that
peculiar particular being precisely in
our everyday preoccupations as though we
were completely abandoned to this or
that region of being so when we're
thinking about say our childcare or how
we're going to do our daily commute or
whether we need to you know put
something else on the grocery list or
any of these mundane preoccupations that
seem so far away from philosophy in
general let alone metaphysics we are
actually engaged with if not the entire
totality of beings at least a an entire
region of beings when we're thinking
about questions that preoccupy ourselves
what we call existential questions that
have to do with death or birth or
trajectory or love or hate or these
other things we are concerned with
entire regions of being now does that
get us to the totality of being
Heidegger says that no matter how
fragmented our everyday existence may
appear to be it always deals with
being in a unity of the whole if only in
a shadowy way great example of this the
ties in with mood when you see somebody
posting on Facebook or on Twitter and
they've you know something bad has
happened that disrupted their day-to-day
existence and you know that that is
perhaps part of the whole cascade of
things happening and they put FML that
is a sort of global statement and it's
not necessarily them being
drama queens or you know engaging in the
kind of posting that that some people do
to call attention themselves if it's
really a genuine authentic expression of
a sort of anguish on their part they are
talking about the totality of things and
the way that the totality is pressing
upon them at that point in time
Heidegger doesn't of course use that as
an example he has some other examples
and he talks about moods or attunement
we're going to talk about certain
features of this in a moment but look at
the first example that he uses that of
boredom he says even and precisely when
we're not actually busy with things or I
solved this as the whole overcomes us
for example in genuine boredom now
notice that there could be boredom
that's not genuine boredom boredom that
is feigned boredom that is only partial
because you actually do have things to
do but I think all of us have
experienced what it's like to be
genuinely bored Heidegger is not going
to provide a detailed phenomenological
description of it here but he's
expecting us to be able to relate to it
he does tell us a few things he says
boredom is distant when it is only in
this book or that play this business or
that idleness that drags on so imagine
being stuck in some business meeting
that you know is going to be over at
five o'clock when you're going to get to
go home and and maybe do something
that's not boring or at least your trip
home will not be boring but you're stuck
there listening to people drone on and
on you're watching a PowerPoint
presentation and you're like oh this is
so mind-numbing something that many of
us have experienced many times
that is what we could call localized
boredom Heidegger is talking about a
more global boredom here he says that
it's something that erupts when one is
bored profound boredom drifting here in
there in the abyss of our existence like
a muffling fog removes all things and
human beings and one's self along with
them into a remarkable and different the
book is boredom is a key point this
boredom reveals beings as a whole so we
like I said are not able to comprehend
the totality intellectually but we are
able to find ourselves in the midst of
things and to grasp them through this
mood of boredom they're at least
revealing a certain side of themselves a
certain possibility of themselves for us
the subject he has another wonderful
example here of joy Heidegger says that
another revelation another possibility
of this is concealed in our joy in the
presence of the design and not simply of
the person of a human being whom we love
now that might sound a little bit
confusing isn't the person the deepest
level if not for Heidegger and this is a
little bit of a technical thing so the
existence the being there of the person
who we love is is more deep less
superficial than the personality of the
person the the individual who we feel
this is love towards and so when we
encounter them and you know like for
example when you you find out something
new about your partner and you rejoice
in it or even something that you already
knew about your partner and you see it
with renewed eyes you haven't seen them
for the day and you come home and you're
so happy to see them that's exactly what
Heidegger is talking about here and that
reveals the world to us not just the
person but the entire world to us in a
different way than say does bored
or we might talk about other global
moods as well like sadness or rage or
envy any any of these sorts of things
that can pervade the entirety of our
existence
now Heidegger is going to go on and tell
us a few other things that are really
key about this so one of these is he
says being attuned lets us find
ourselves among beings as a whole and he
said that the this you know the founding
mode of attunement and this is in german
deep affinity character skimming right
or bish dimming right
these are either terms that he's going
to use quite often it allows us to grasp
the the totality of beings but not in an
intellectual way in an effective way it
can have intellectual correlates we
might say it reveals beings as a whole
and he says that this is not incidental
this is something essential to human
being to design to the kind of being
that we are so what this implies is that
we should not expect that our emotional
side is something that we ought to
simply strip away or prescind from or
abstract from if we want to get at the
real so he goes on and he says what we
call a feeling is neither a transitory
epiphenomenon of our thinking and
willing behavior right it's not just a
reflection of thinking and willing nor
simply an impulse that provokes such
behavior nor merely a present condition
we have to put up somehow or other it
could be that some some feeling some
moods actually do fit into that debt
categorization but they reveal something
deeper to us or at least they have the
potentiality to do so by you might say
globalizing and he goes on now and this
is where we get to something really
important he says when moods of this
sort bring us face to face with beings
as a whole they reveal something to us
but while they reveal they also conceal
so while they reveal while they show
something to
they also conceal they also hide
something from us what are they hiding
in in most cases with the exception of
one mood that Heidegger is going to talk
about in considerable detail they are
hiding from us the nothing most moods
don't take into account than nothing and
that is something that's going to be key
for Heidegger because in this inquiry
what is metaphysics we are concerned
with the metaphysical question of the
nothing so is there a mood that could
reveal to us the nothing Heidegger
thinks that there is and that mood is
anxiety
you